Seguimos pendientes de lo que ocurre con
Ana el activista y bloguero egipcio que
lleva más de 200 días en huelga de
hambre y desde el domingo coincidiendo
con el inicio de la Cumbre del clima
tampoco está bebiendo agua a su familia
no ha sabido nada de él en todos estos
días su madre ha montado Guardia en la
prisión pero no ha recibido la carta que
generalmente se les entrega semanalmente
como prueba de vida Hoy a primera hora
han anunciado los medios de comunicación
que a la habría sido intervenido
médicamente sin ningún tipo de
autorización y de contacto con la
familia lo cual dicen que podría
considerarse tortura porque se estaría
haciendo en contra de la voluntad del
activista que dice que está dispuesto a
morir en prisión sería la única vía de
salida que les quedaría otra noticia que
supimos hace muy poco es que su abogado
jaled Ali podría haberle visitado en
prisión porque la fiscalía así lo había
autorizado pero acaba de comunicar hace
escasos minutos que no se le ha
permitido hacerlo debido a un tecnicismo
en el cual se asegura que no puede
visitar al convicto porque solamente se
firmó ayer la autorización y según la
normativa egipcia tendría al menos una
semana para hacerlo también su hermana
sana que a la que hemos oído hablar en
la Cumbre del clima y denunciar la
situación de los Derechos Humanos en
Egipto se ha vuelto en su contra el
haber venido a Egipto y el haber tenido
la valentía de hablar en favor de su
hermano o un abogado egipcio habría
emprendido acciones legales contra ella
acusándola de difundir noticias falsas
una acusación que es precisamente la que
mantiene a su hermano en la cárcel desde
hace años en Solidaridad con alá del
fatal y con los más de 60.000
prisioneros políticos que hay en Egipto
en este momento en la Cumbre del clima y
en muchos otros lugares en Egipto los
ciudadanos y los activistas además de
periodistas están vistiéndose de blanco
llevando una camiseta o pañuelo blanco
como ha pedido José ambas gad el
defensor del derechos humanos que
trabajo con La Iniciativa egipcia